vous avez employé vous même dans votre
intervention à l'assemblée en début de
semaine des mots très durs ont déjà on
disait déjà composée d'êtres un parieur
vous avez dit que ce qui se faisait
c'était un crime et donc mais c'était
prévisible que la russie allait mettre
son veto sur une résolution qui les
condamnait êtes vous déçu
mais je suis pas surprise c'était 7 est
inévitable à cause d'une menace d'un
veto pour pour la russie on n'est pas
surpris mais en fait en moi dissensions
dans le fonds commun en europe et avec
et je crois qu'on a vu une solidité de
l'alliance des pays qui sont très
remuants
l'activité de monsieur
il n'y a pas de doute qu'il y à des
crimes de guerre
qui existe à cause de l'activité de la
lose it ses pairs que ce contrat voire
internationale vous avez des qg j'ai dit
des mots durs on n'a pas le choix les
moules de la diplomatie
ne sont pas suffisants pour vraiment
répondre dans la situation où il faut
reconnaître que
tous ont des enfants
attaquant des appartements nier
l'existence de tout à l'époque toute une
population
le tout une nationalité ni et même
l'existence de de l'état de l'état
ukrainien par hasard
c'est un aspect de la cance et
génocidaire qui existe à la tête de
monsieur de monsieur poutine doit comme
tellement un dictateur comme il est mais
même les dictateurs doivent comprendre
qu'il y a des conséquences pour pour les
activités pour les enfants comme il
vient de faire et est
rentable très difficile pour la
population iranienne ne peut pas prédire
exactement ce qui va arriver j'espère
que
demande
parce qu'évidemment on peut se demander
si on a été naïfs sont à sous-estimer
poutine au cours de toutes ces semaines
les états unis.vers raison de sonner
l'alarmé mais on est deux noms que lui
ferait il ne le fera pas en envoyer des
millions de dollars tous les pays on
envoyait des armes et tout ça et
pourtant kiev et céline ce qu'il annonce
ce soir tristement dans une vidéo
pourrait tomber sous les bombardements
russes sous les chars russes
qu'est ce que vous ressentez quand vous
entendez quelle analyse faites-vous de
la station ce moment ci qu'on doit
résister
la dictature qu'on doit résister d etat
qu quand la souveraineté d'un peuple et
qu'on doit reconnaître
l'intégralité territoriale de la nation
du canada je crois que c'est important
oui c'est triste et difficile c'est
c'est une tragédie que nous voyons avec
la perte de vies
avec tout ce qui arrive mais ça veut pas
dire que que en garde de temps pour le
faire non pas du tout celui qui sort du
maquis car et c'est l'existence
politique d'un pays mais qu'est ce qu'on
veut de nouveau appuyé pas ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait l'otan n'interviendra pas
parce que le crâne n'est pas membre de
l'otan
poutine appelle les militaires un coup
d'état et deux militaires grenier prenez
le pouvoir et en même temps du même
souffle et dit venez à minsk à négocier
mais capituler avant qu'est-ce qu'on
répond aux sablons résiste à ça
il faut les en tout genre de choses
monsieur côté certains c'est un probant
en bagarre 10,2
le premier temps c'est ce qui va faire
et il me demande toujours appuyé la
gouvernance duquel nous devons toujours
appuyé la fonde
et de la population à 8 mais elles
devront continuer avec les san siro même
qu'il deux cas marine au sud soudan mais
c'est plutôt un examen nous nous sommes
en faveur des sanctions pour pour
la système swift comme en appel pour
toutes tout le système bancaire du mans
que la rue soit soient expulsés de ce
système nous sommes d'accord avec cela
continuons d'insister sur la confiance
de la solidarité le gouvernement
allemand a déclaré à la fin de la
journée au prix qu'ils sont d'accord
avec nous en aurons fait on va continuer
le progrès c'est très difficile c'est
pas facile aux digues mais allez-y faire
le combat avec avec les russes coach
c'est un pouvoir nucléaire c'est pas
chaque jour comment comment faire une
telle décision sans vraiment penser sur
les conséquences et c'est ce que fait
l'otan nous avons continué le vert
lumineux parce qu'il a primé mais on va
continuer sur moi sur la voie de non
seulement de la diplomatie mais des
efforts comme on peu près ce que je
pensais que pousser d'avoir réussi à
remobiliser latin permettre aux états
unis d'assumer à nouveau une sorte de
leadership
mais cette mobilisation de l'otan est ce
un signal que on craint poussines ont
craint qu'il n'aille au delà de
l'ukraine qui lie dans les pays baltes
que les deux côtés de la pologne de la
mauldre enfin qu'en pensez vous et 2 de
voisins dans deux mondes aux valeurs qui
sont la géorgie qui sort qui sont les
voisins de la russie à skis par les
attaquer est-ce qu'il va inventer les
causes pour qu'elles évacuent les au
monsieur poutine a parlé de vampires
rose il veut retourner aux frontières du
passé ça c'est ça c'est le langage des
toiles il faut quand on utilise de même
le même de même les mêmes phases
exactement les mêmes idées et
l'expansion mail de la pension ils
tendent les bras qu'est-ce qu'ils
parlent qu'est ce qu'il pense qu'on va
pas me répondre en arrivant mais que moi
mais il faut commencer avec dès
maintenant on attend on apprend qu'elle
est pour parler pour
la dénucléarisation
entre la russie des etats-unis s'est
interrompue il ya beaucoup de boycott
boycottage de produits russes les
frontières même de l'impact dans les
sports va y a plusieurs conséquences on
peut penser qu'il y en a qui craint que
c'est le peuple russe l'hébreu 1 c'est
le peuple russe qui pourraient souffrir
et vous aurez des problèmes
mais ce que je sais c'est une grande
grande mobilisation partout et beaucoup
de capital qui sont en bleu et jaune ce
soir et vous l'avez mentionné il veut
recréer le passé donc c'est presque
nouvelle guerre froide qui est en train
de se de se préparer
à ce moment mais après je ne suis pas
une guerre fois mais on me l'a appris en
support après on ne sait jamais ce qu'a
causé monsieur côté ils venaient mais
l'ordre mondial le monde doit
reconnaître
c'est que exercer une telle agression
quand un autre pays sans aucune raison
et inventer toutes les choses il a
inventé qu'il invente sur le jour j des
avants c'est pas c'est pas la langue de
la démocratie pas le langage du chien du
champ des nations unies que je cherche
toujours
avec moi
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on veut on attend
qu'ils avaient la balle va arriver ça va
ça va bousculer les choses ça va exiger
une réponse différente de la barre de
tous les pays qui croît dans un an dans
un ordre de règles dans un respect y
court pour la personnalité humaine est
naturellement veut retourner à la
diplomatie
avoir une vie normale
assurément mais c'est monsieur monsieur
poutine qui est responsable pour la
facture d'une certaine sens de consensus
de ventes qui existait et
doit comprendre qu'il y aura des
conséquences ils ont continué d'essayer
d'éviter une guerre même plus longue
même plus difficile mais en même temps
on doit reconnaître de là l'importance
de la justice pour la population et pour
nous devons montrer continué de montrer
une solidarité importante pour pour ce
pays qui se soit va trouver une
situation tellement difficile le monde
ici sait lire et ça m'avait se
convaincre que le canada va ouvrir ses
portes aux réfugiés craignais oui oui il
écoute le second oui naturellement nous
allons accepter de le juger c'est ce que
canada pcc le canada dont on parle sachs
acteur des réfugiés nous acceptons de
vigueur de partout et c'est
naturellement mal fait mais on va le
faire d'une façon de régler avec avec
nos partenaires en europe et autres
mordus de la population monsieur ray
merci beaucoup nous avoir parlé depuis
les nations unies ce soir depuis new
york une résolution a subi le veto de la
russie sans grande surprise on attend
l'avenir merci monsieur rêve en soirée
des droits de l'enfant